Hey there crazies.
I was just having this conversation with question
clone:
Why am I this size?
Well, you’re human and you're my clone, so you have to be this size.
Then, why are humans this size?
Oh wow, that’s a great topic for a video! I've got to think about this.
Hey! Where are you going?
So, let’s see what we can do with this.
First, we could have just as easily been a
slightly different size
as we can see from the usual suspects.
I mean, that’s just chance.
Yeah, but why aren’t we way bigger?
Because not everything scales the same way
and a normal-sized human is kind of like a
scale model of a giant human,
so let’s make a list!
Things that scale with volume include:
mass, which can affect how you resist changes
in your motion,
Weight, which is how much gravity pulls down
on you,
and heat generated, because you have more
cells doing more stuff.
Things that scale with area include:
bone & muscle strength, because that’s related
to cross-section,
and heat dissipated, because that’s related
to exposed skin area.
Side note!
Don’t ever let anyone tell you that you
lose more heat through your head.
You lose heat through any exposed
skin, no matter where it is.
End of side note!
OK, let’s say I made a clone that was, I
don’t know, 10 times taller,
They’d have 1000 times the mass, 1000 times
the weight,
and would be generating 1000 times as much
heat.
Yikes!
But unfortunately, they’d only have 100
times the strength
and they’d only be dissipating 100 times
the heat.
So, basically, they wouldn’t have the strength
to move their body,
their bones would break under the weight of
their body,
and they’d burn up from the inside until
all their organs shut down.
But?
Yes, there used to be things like dinosaurs
and mammoths
But?
Yes, there are still elephants and giraffes.
But what about?
And yes, floating can take some of the weight
off the bones and muscles
so aquatic animals have an easier time being
bigger.
The point is, humans can’t be that big.
So, then why aren’t we way smaller?
Mmm, that one is a little harder.
The big problem here is our thought holes.
Also known as our brains.
Brains!
Brain cells, or neurons, are some of the smallest cells in
the human body, at least in diameter,
and it still takes a brain this big to give
us our level of intelligence.
But don’t elephants have?
OK, OK, it’s not just about brain size.
Larger animals like elephants have bigger
brains than us.
In fact, they have about 3 times as many neurons.
But that doesn’t mean the elephant is 3
times smarter than us.
Naturally bigger animals have bigger brains
because there’s more stuff to control.
Over 97% of those elephant neurons are found
in the cerebellum.
the part of the brain most responsible for
motor control.
It needs all those neurons just to control
all its giant clunky parts.
So, what about a brain-to-body mass ratio?
Something like that has been suggested before.
We called it an “Encephalization Quotient”
or EQ,
which is the ratio between actual brain mass
and the brain mass we predict would be necessary
to control the body.
Cats have an EQ of 1,
chimps about 2.5,
bottlenose dolphins between 4-5,
and humans sit comfortably at about 7.
That certainly puts us on top!
But we usually attribute intelligence to the
cerebral cortex,
which is that wrinkly part on the outside
our brains
and only mammals have it.
Which is pretty arrogant if you ask me, limiting intelligence
to mammals.
Crows are pretty smart and they don’t have
a cerebral cortex.
Octopuses are really smart and they don’t
have a cerebral cortex.
In fact, 2/3 of their neurons are in their
arms,
which are not tentacles, by the way.
These neurons allow each arm to act independently
of the others and the central brain,
it’s a completely different kind of intelligence.
OK, I concede, intelligence is complicated.
But there is another problem you’d run into
if you were smaller: your lungs.
If you get small enough, like insect small,
lungs are unnecessary.
It would be more energy efficient to just
absorb oxygen through the skin.
Insects do it through little holes in their
exoskeleton.
Super Main Ultimate Point:
Different size organisms have to work with
a different set of rules.
Our rules only work at our size.
But here’s the real question:
Why do we have any size at all?
We’ll try to find an answer on the next
episode of The Science Asylum.
Make sure you subscribe so you don’t
miss it.
Thanks for liking and sharing this video.
And until next time, remember, it’s OK to
be a little crazy.
In the last video, we talked Planck Units.
Comment response time!
Rogue Assassin Gaming was wondering if Planck
Length is the shortest length,
then could Planck Time would be the shortest
amount of time?
Yes, in fact, the same models of quantum gravity
say that about length and time.
But again, they don’t have any experimental
evidence.
So, for now, Planck Time is just the time
it takes light to travel one Planck Length.
and, as we said in the video, it was the age
of the universe when it was one Planck Length across.
PapaKay heard one time that measuring the
Planck scale would create a black hole.
Well, maybe.
A typical way to measure the position of a
particle is to use light
and the wavelength of that light is your precision.
To measure Planck Length, that photon has to have
an energy of 12 billion joules.
or over 6 Planck Energies.
Basically, you just turned a fruit fly into
one photon.
That much mass-energy would make a black hole
if it were smooshed into a Planck Length.
But, just because the photon has a wavelength
that small,
it doesn’t mean that’s the size of the
photon.
Wavelength and size are not necessarily the
same thing.
Camo Rovak suggested we should switch to a
Base-12 or Base-16 number system.
You know, 12 does have a lot more factors
than 10,
so it would certainly make writing decimals easier.
But I think you’d have a hard time convincing
anyone to change.
We can’t even get the U.S. to switch to the metric system.
Pablo had some very astute criticisms about
using black body radiation to define
Planck Temperature.
For those of you who don’t know, black body
radiation is just light emitted by objects
due solely to it's temperature, so basically the vibrations and collisions between molecules.
It’s commonly stated that if an object is
Planck Temperature hot,
then it would emit light that has a wavelength
of one Planck Length.
But the problem with saying this is not
just one kind of photon is emitted by the object.
Black body radiation is distributed over many
wavelengths.
You’re emitting it right now, it’s just
mostly infrared.
One Planck Temperature gives you a peak
wavelength of one Planck Length.
Something could be at half a Planck Temperature
and still be emitting light at one Planck Length,
just not as much.
And to anyone like Infinity Pool who thinks
this channel doesn’t get enough attention.
Share the videos all the places!
Anyway, thanks for watching!